[موسيقى]
يتجول هواه السفر حول العالم لاستكشاف
التاريخ والاثار او الاستجمام والتسوق لكن
في جمهوريه بيرو الامر مختلف الطعام هو
الجاذب الرئيسي للسياح
المطبخ البيروفي واحد من اكثر المطابخ
تنوعا حول العالم ورغم تاريخ بيرو القديم
الممتد عبر الزمن الى انها تشتهر ايضا
بفنون الطبخ وبمزيج متنوع من الاطعمه
والوجبات والتي يعتبرها السكان مصدر فخر
لهم وعنصر جذب فريد للسياح
الطعام هو من اهم اسباب السفر فسرعان ما
تدرك ان للمطبخ مكانه فكانتا مهمه جدا انه
ثقافه حقيقيه
واحده من الطاهات المهارات في البلاد بعد
عملها طاهيه في الولايات المتحده عادت الى
مدينه ليما عاصمه بيرو وعاصمه الطعام في
امريكا الجنوبيه كما يصفها اهلها
توفر فرصه للسياح للتعرف على بلدها بشكل
مختلف عن طريق الطعام
لمعرفه مدينه ما وان كنت تحب الطعام عليك
التوجه مباشره الى السوق
سكان بيرو يعشقون الطبخ المنزلي ولديهم
نحو ثلاثه الاف طبق مختلف من الاطعمه نتجه
هذا الكم الهائل من الاطباق عن طريق موجات
عديده من المهاجرين عبر مئات السنين
المطبخ هنا هو عباره عن مزيج من التاثيرات
القادمه من حضارات عده منها حضاره الانكا
والاسبانيه واليابانيه والافريقيه والقليل
من الفرنسيات ايضا طعام الشارع علامه
مميزه في بيرو عليك التوقف في طوابر طويله
للحصول على احدى الوجبات المتميزه هنا
ما نحضره هنا هو اسياخ من اللحم البقري
وقوانص الدجاج وقلوبه كنت ارغب في القيام
بذلك لان اجدادي كانوا من باعه هذه
المنتجات انا مستمره ببيعها
وجبه اوصال الدجاج هذه كانت الطعام
الطبقات الفقيره في البلاد لكنها مع الوقت
اصبحت من رموز المطبخ البيروفي يتناولها
الفقراء والاغنياء والسياح على حد سواء
الثروه السمكيه هنا ضخمه وهي واحده من اهم
الموارد الرئيسيه للاقتصاد في البلاد ومن
الطبيعي ان يكون للماكولات البحريه
شعبيتها الكبيره ايضا كبيره
اصطدم ما يقارب الثمانين كيلوغراما البحر
في بيروغاني بسبب المحيط الهادئ وتيارات
المياه الدافئه القادمه منه والتي تدعى
نينيو وبسبب وفره العوالق البحريه
والانسجه البيروفيه في نهايه كل يوم يعود
مانويل الى زوجته محملا بما منحه له البحر
من اسماه لتصنع له طبقا فريدا ورمزا من
رموز المطبخ البيروفي انه طبق السيفيتشي
هو السمك الطازج الذي خرج من البحر للتو
والذي نضيف له الثوم والفلفل والملح
والليمون تقول الاسطوره ان الصيادين خرجوا
الى البحر وعلقوا هناك كان لديهم فقط
السمك والليمون وهكذا اعدوا طبق السوفيتشي
الطهات الشباب في بيرو لديهم شغف متواصل
لتطوير وجباتهم التقليديه واستكشاف وجبات
جديده لاصعاد السكان وابهار السياح بوجبات
لم يتذوقوها في اي مكان اخر
[موسيقى]